todesdrama auf der urlaubsinsel usedom
beim absturz eines alten kleinflugzeugs
bei heringsdorf kam am sonntag der pilot
ums leben
der mann hatte am vormittag mit seiner
einmotorigen oldtimer maschine einen
übungsflug absolvieren wollen
die pilatus pc 2 stieg von der staat bei
einem flughafen heringsdorf auf in einer
höhe von 40 metern geschah dann das
unglück aus bisher ungeklärter ursache
stürzte das flugzeug gegen 10 uhr 15
über unbebautem gebiet ab der pilot
starb ein copilot der ebenfalls in der
unglücksmaschine gesessen hatte
überlebte den absturz
er wurde schwer verletzt aus dem wrack
geborgen und kam in ein krankenhaus
nun ermitteln die behörden jetzt
zugeschaltet bild reporter sven hadorn
ist wenn sag uns was weiß man jetzt
alles über den toten
guten morgen aus rostock hatte tote ist
wie schon erwähnt der ehemalige gründer
und chef der bäckereikette lina becker
die insbesondere hier in brandenburg und
im mclaren vor trauern sehr bekannt ist
in ihren besten zeiten hatte die kette
400 filialen 2700 mitarbeiter und einen
jahresumsatz von 100 millionen euro
der volker schecke ist ein gelernter
elektrotechnik gerade frühjahr zu ddr
zeiten hier in der lpg in vorpommern
gearbeitet hat 1989 ist dann mit seiner
frau über ungarn in den westen
geflüchtet ist 1990 zurückgekehrt und
hat hier in vorpommern dann sind ersten
frischemarkt eröffnet und den ersten
deutschen verkauft dann hat er über
einen westdeutschen freund 10
ausrangierte alte backöfen hierüber
geholt und hat dann erst den ersten
bäckereien gegründet hat sich dann immer
weiter erweitert und therapie sein
imperium aufgebaut
nach mehreren fusionen und durch den
einstieg von finanzinvestoren war es
dann so dass er mehr oder weniger als im
unternehmen herausgedrängt worden ist
selbst sagt es ausgeschieden
vor zwei jahren hat er sich
zurückgezogen und hat dann hier am
flughafen heringsdorf seinen hangar 10
aufgebaut das ist eine große flugzeug
ausstellung insbesondere
kampfflugzeuge aus den 30er und 40er
jahren stehen dort ist ein
leidenschaftlicher sammler und
leidenschaftlicher flieger
er hat mal in einem interview vor zwei
jahren gesagt es ist sogar weltrang
weltranglisten gibt in denen gewertet
wird
die oft piloten solche alten maschinen
fliegen und er sei schon hat er den
ersten zehn
und sein ziel sei es an die spitze zu
kommen
diese leidenschaft endete für ihn jetzt
tödlich weiß man mittlerweile schon
etwas mehr dazu wie es zu diesem unfall
kommen konnte
also bekannt ist bislang dass die
maschine aus 40 metern abgestürzt ist in
ein getreidefeld mann hatte vorher eine
leichte linkskurve geflogen das wetter
war eigentlich gut
stand jetzt ist die ursache immer noch
unklar man hat gestern abend bereits den
flugschreiber gefunden
dort sind ja die gespräche zwischen den
piloten aufgezeichnet bzw alle flugdaten
registriert und man erhofft sich dass
man da möglicherweise neue erkenntnisse
gewinnen kann
die flugunfalluntersuchung aus
braunschweig war gestern bereits vor ort
auch die kriminalpolizei anklam mann
ermittelt erst mal wegen verdachts der
fahrlässigen tötung
inwieweit ein materialfehler die
maschine ist ja immerhin 70 jahre alt
vorliegt oder ein oder auch menschliches
versagen